Oh gotcha I'm not gonna let go I've
never got an echo never Oh
I let go up here comes a bubble bobble
Bobble bobble Bobble you're so small hi
guys I want to wish you all a very Merry
Christmas and happy holidays to everyone
that doesn't celebrate Christmas I hope
you guys are currently with your friends
and family and I'm very happy to say
that I am home which is something that I
haven't been able to say for a long time
oh here comes Maggie that one Oh Maggie
oh my goo goo Alma goobie oh my goo B oh
my goodness Magoo birth omegate okay
oh thank you yeah I am home and it's
good to be here it's good to be around
my family again it's good to see my
friends again and it always just feels
calmer here than la mostly because it is
traffic is less there's less people here
and generally it's just a bit more
easygoing and it always feels grounding
to be around my friends and I was really
happy to be able to do the charity
livestream I still don't know the final
tally of the amount raised but I know we
were very close to our hundred and fifty
thousand dollar goal but but more over
than that I just like being back here
because it reminds me of you know why
started all of this and why I decided to
do this because I I think I think I
think early on in my career on YouTube
my career on YouTube I I landed on the
right attitude towards what I wanted to
do with this channel it was to spread
joy and bring happiness and do some good
for the world around me and and I look
back four and a half years ago when I
first started in this very house and I
just see the progress that we've made
since that time and I look back and I
remember all the different things we've
done all the different challenges like
we have faced and I say we as in you and
me I'm
not talking about me and my friends we
face challenges ourselves but like you
and I like we have come a long long way
and some of you may not have been here
this whole time and that's totally fine
I know I know there's so many of you out
there and it's hard to imagine the sheer
magnitude of living every day of your
life with more and more people walking
through the door but I remember that
Keith back back when I first started and
I could communicate with every single
subscriber individually and the wonder
of that time it was a beautiful thing
and not saying it's turned into an ugly
thing if anything it's even more
beautiful than it was before because the
charity livestream that we did yesterday
is an indication of that very same
spirit that we started the channel with
hey none of that bobble I know you want
up but it's Maggie's turn ok ha ha
don't whine no no no I'll still bless
you anyway that that same spirit that I
started the channel with and the idea
that we were going to spread joy and we
were gonna do good and we were oh I'm
trying to talk here trying to talk none
of that wrong a boopie on the nose done
cheese where's Lucy
hi Lucy ha welcome to party I was in the
middle of something and then you all
interrupt now sit and stay still sit
still good girl Lizzie I know you can't
send my lap cuz you're too huge but I'll
play with you after the video step ok
it's fascinating to see that same spirit
burning and not just my heart and hearts
of my friends who have been inspired to
do things and and it's even weird to
think that I inspired my friends to do
good but Bob told me as much during
livestream yesterday and it really like
those words really resonated with me
like knowing that I introduced this
concept of not that I started this
concept now
by anymore but I introduced this concept
that what I do here on YouTube and
playing games and having fun with with
friends and family and you guys could
lead to good in the world
that's an amazing feeling and I I always
get in a mood of self-reflection when I
come back here and I know it's easy to
get lost in the the dismay of like this
year 2016 has been quite a year and I
know it's easy to get lost in the the
general pessimism of what seems to go on
because in this day and age everything
is about sharing but I think sometimes
people forget that it's so important to
share the right things and it's so
important to share the right message
because as a species we're programmed to
look at disaster and be like oh that is
fascinating but we got to remember that
we look at that as a warning so that we
don't allow that to control our lives
and then that's all we hear even on the
internet or in our daily lives and that
becomes like the chorus of our entire
existence like the theme song of our
life becomes this depressing parade and
that's not what I ever want to do I only
ever want to bring joy and I always feel
more connected with that when I'm with
my family and with my friends and I and
I'm doing things that I'm so proud of
doing and I'm making videos that make me
laugh as much as they make you laugh and
I just wanted to say that I'm very very
happy with where I am and with who I am
and even though I'm 27 years old I'm not
done growing up I've come a long long
way from the person I was when I started
this channel and I've hit roadblocks and
I've hit obstacles and I've hit
challenges and I have overcome them and
some I have not overcome yet but I'm so
happy with
the fact that I've been able to stay
true to this course that we you and I
are able to stay true to what we do here
on this channel which is at its core
spread joy and happiness to everyone the
needs and that is why I'm happy to be
home and while I'm here I plan to do
some videos with my mother who you guys
have only seen briefly in pictures and
in small snippets of videos but I have
an idea she's been learning to do a very
very good nail decoration so I think I'm
gonna have her do my nails because she
needs to practice and I need to get my
nails done because they're horrid and I
think I'm going to have her try to play
a game and I think I know exactly the
game that she needs to play I believe
I'm gonna try to get my mom to play five
nights at freddys and she is not gonna
know what the hell to do but my mom is
the most unintentionally hilarious
person I know
I could start a book series on texts
from my mom text from my mom she is the
funniest texture on the face of the
earth and if you guys want to see some
of those let me know down in the
comments if you want to see a specific
game for us to play let us know down in
the comments and expect the nail
painting video very soon but for now I'm
going to celebrate Christmas with my
doggies I'm celebrating Christmas with
my family and I'm gonna spend a good
while kind of relaxing while at the same
time getting videos to you guys because
the thing I plan to do while I'm here is
play nothing but indie horror games
because I've been stockpiling a list of
them and saving it just for this
occasion when I'm back home in my old
recording room and in my old recording
setup and able to make videos for you
guys so that should be a lot of fun but
at the end of it all just thank you guys
so much
being here with me on this amazing
journey that is not yet over
and I have no idea when it's going to
end but hopefully the spirit of what we
do here always carries on so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
bubble for being a rambunctious little
stinker Thank You Maggie for being such
a good girl and thank you everybody
again for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye boo
boo boo boo boo boos that's gross
[Music]